Ви знаєте, що зрештою відповідальність за
відправку військового обладнання в Україну
несе
командувач російських військ, тому нам
важче знати, звідки надійшов цей конкретний наказ,
але майте на увазі, що спільна
слідча група має велику
кількість перехоплених комунікацій, які
також є частиною справи, тож, можливо,
у нас є людина, яка подала запит
на ракетну установку, і ми можемо побачити, до кого
надійшов цей запит, і тоді ми зможемо
зрозуміти, з ким вони насправді повинні були
поговорити, щоб це
сталося.  ми неодноразово бачили приклади
бомбардувань лікарень у Сирії, і
ми також бачили у відповідь
спростування російського міністерства оборони, і
ми досліджували ці спростування
знову і знову вони створюють
аерофотознімки супутникові зображення вони, як ви знаєте,
стверджують, що щось не бомбили  і
виявилося, що його розбомбили, я знаю,
один приклад: вони стверджують, що не
бомбили мечеть, а те, що вони там зробили,
це Пренті  аерофотознімок сутності, який показує
зовсім інший мох, вони сказали, що
ми бомбардуємо ІДІЛ, і ось де це
відбувається, ми змогли знайти, де було
знято кожне з цих відео,
і лише одне з них було ціллю на контрольованій
ІДІЛ території, коли перевірки
показали  вони лежали навколо
цілей, які вони бомбили, вони дали нам
стільки низьких плодів, ми, ви знаєте,
що вони висувають претензії,
Міністерство оборони Росії каже, що ми не
бомбили цю лікарню, ми перевіряємо інформацію з відкритих
джерел, і виявляється або
кожного разу, коли вони брешуть про
Росію, вона настільки спритна в веденні
військової розвідки, обману і тому подібного,
але якщо багато брехати, це робить тебе
хорошим брехуном, і це проблема.
Росія щаслива, що вони дуже добре вміють брехати
і раніше це було слово Росії
проти заходу, тепер, якби Росія
перестала брехати про це, нам
не було б що писати про
Росію